uh what
does exactly mean and what does it
signify for the Muslims
alhamdulillah the meaning of the
word l means
night means decree or power or high
esteem or Majesty soad means night of
power or night of decree or night of
majesty or night of high esteem and as
far as the virtues of is concerned it is
one of the best nights in the month of
Ramadan rather it is the best night in
the full year and this for the night in
which the Quran was revealed and Allah
subhana says in the Quran
in chapter number 97 verse number 1
to5 which means that indeed we have
revealed this message that is the Quran
in the the night of power in the night
of decree and what will explain to thee
what is the night of power the night of
power is better than a thousand
months therein the spirit and the angels
they descend with the permission of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala at every
end peace this until mour so from this
verse of the Quran we come to know that
this night of light
the night of power the night of decree
is the best night in the full year and
this was the night in which the Quran
was revealed and further says that this
night is of power of majesty of high
esteem and of dignity and any good deed
that is done in this night is better
than what is done in a thousand months
and if you divide thousand months by 12
it comes to more than 83 years
and that is much more than the average
life of a human being so if you do
worship in this one night it is better
then doing worship for your full life
and further it says that this is the
night when the angels and the spirit
they descend down with the permission of
Allah subhana tala and in this night
there is peace till morning and further
it's mentioned in the Quran in suran
chapter number 44 verse number three and
four that we have revealed the message
the Glorious Quran in this blessed night
and we warn you from the evil and in it
we ordain what has been decreed and this
night also means
measurement and it's mentioned in the
Quran in surar chapter number 54 verse
number 49 that verily we have created
all things in due proportion and
measure
so also mean somewhat like it's the
night of decree when Allah subhah wa
ta'ala sends down the
decree
the what is going to happen in the full
year from this to next that's the reason
I beloved Prophet M wasallam said it's
mentioned in s
bukari poem number three in the book of
superiority
of Hadith number 20114 that anyone who
prays in the night
of with faith and seeking Allah's reward
all his past sins will be forgiven so
these are the virtues of the night
of indeed a wonderful night and I pray
and wish that we can all find that night
this year inshallah during this blessed
month of Ramadan